the opportunity and upshot of doing your
own thing is that you can lower the
percentage of things you're doing that
you sort of resent or like you feel like
you're sacrificing right in a job you
may just have like too many things and
this was my case like I was just doing
too many things that I thought were
Silly pointless or just like grueling to
power through and like I still do some
of those things it's just less
so it means there's more space for that
creativity and curiosity to stay alive
and that is really important to me
and if it's important to you it's
possible and I think this is kind of
what I was trying to get at and don't
find a niche find a mode of being in
which you can show up if you can find
that I think like ambition is really
just like how fast you want to go at
that point
[Music]